στο σπίτι της κραδίας γνωριστικάμε μέσω διαδεκτίου γνωριστικαμε ασχολείτε με τη στοπλ καμιασχέδεν ένα χενεσστο
πλεάνιγια τα να ήταν εκανε στίβον καιχορών σε πιοεν αρελιγιαν αντιλαμβάνεται τη σημαίνει προταθρητισμός το
καρο που τη γνώρι σας πουδάζε και στην ουσίαν όταν εγώ μου κροατιάν από την
πρώτη μαρτίου μέχχρικοσι κάτι μαρτίου ήταν το πλάνντοίκο κσ πλάκωσε το κόβη ήρθαντα λόκτα ακυρώθηκε
να γώ να σπίχα στη μαϊόρκα ι διαρχίσαμε να αρχόμαστε πιο κοντακή και σίγορα βοήθησε
το κόι γιατί αρχιζαμε να σισδούμε κλειδωθήκαν μέσα σπίτι μαζί στην ξια και ενόημουν σε
μια φάσει τις ζωής μου που είχαν παροποίδες είχαφρένωχιρόφρενο στο να κάνω σχέσι παράληρα κατάλαβα
ότι αυτή ήταν γυναίκα τη ζωήσμα αυτή ήτανγίναίκα που θέλα εμητέρα τω παιδιόου και λέω
του πάύλοέιύπναμνειςε βλάκας φύγεται τς παροποίδες φύγετα στόπερ και απλά δες που μπορεί να φτάσει
και στην ουσία πολύ γρήγορα συντεθήκαμεεπάρα πολύ και εγώ ι διαπ τοκατοκαίριστην οθίάντηρώτη μετά κάτι
πουχαμε συζητήσει τη ρώότησ πότε θα κάνουμε μορών κάτι που δεν το περίμενε δωσο συντομαναδηρωτήσω
και γεννήθηκε λιωνίδας μα στον δεκαίύριον του κίανα ο μικρός λεων ίδας πως άλλαξε τη
ζωτοπάύλοπος αλλάξετων πάύλο σαάνθρωπο του έδωσεν άλλη προπτυχιστή ζωή να αντηριυθεί ότι δεν είναι μόνο
στιοπλοια ηζωή αλλά είναι και οικογένειασου που είναι πιο σημαντικών γιατί οιογινα σοταν παντοτειγή ενοιστεοπλοα
κάποια στιγμή θα σταματήσει να γωνίζεσε το άχιστων σεολημπιαγόν επίπεδο και να κάτιμο βοηθίζε παρά
πολύ και μετά το τοκιο θα παρολών που με τον τρόπ που ήρθα αυτήτα αρτη
θέση